食べる？
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
あのー、すごい意味不明なこと言います
僕ー、滑ってみたいんですよ
いやそのね、氷の上とかでもなくて
結露した床とかでもなくて
僕は普段のこの日常生活におけるー、普通の床で俺は滑ってみたい
分かる人いるかな？
小学校の時の、掃除の時間
廊下を雑巾拭きした後の廊下濡れるじゃないですか
あの濡れてる廊下
っていうのは
皆さん想像つくと思うんですけど
めちゃくちゃ滑るんすよ
あの分かる？こう
あの内履きで
きゅっていくだけで
すーって滑っていく、あの感覚
あの感覚をちょっと取り戻したいと思っています
そこで僕はある商品に目を付けました。
こちら
滑るブルー
いかにも怪しいですよね、滑るブルー
なんかシリコンスプレーというものなんですけども
普通に探してたらあって
これなんだろうと思ってよく見たら
滑るスプレーなんすよ
これを使えば、物が、滑るようになる
今回も簡単明快です
この滑るスプレーを使って、僕ん家の床を滑るようにして
分かるか？ホント多分わかる人には分かると思うんですけど
あの、スーって行く感じね
あの雑巾拭きで廊下を拭いた後の
ちょっと水がたくさん…、は、か、なっている床をこの走って
ピタッと止まった瞬間にスーっと滑るあの動摩擦係数がない感じよ
たまんないんすよ、ホントに
小学校の掃除当番だった時に
絶対廊下掃除が好きだったんで
僕はもう廊下掃除しかしたくなかったんです
っていうわけで今日は
滑るスプレーを使って
滑る床を作りたいと思います
石油系溶剤が入ってる
あ！やば！やばいやばい！
吸入飲料不可
人体に害がありますので絶対吸わないで下さい
通気の良いところで使用してください
バナナも移動しなきゃ
バナナも毒になっちゃうから
ちょっと実際に軽く使ってみましょう
あ、前髪切りました
とりあえずどれくらい滑るかっていうのを知りたいんですよね
普通の机にまず使ってみます
いきます
ヴーヴァーヴア
これで果たしてどれくらい滑るようになるかっすね
もう、もういいのかな？
おう！
あ！くっさ！
ウヴェエエェェ
ちょっと触ってみます
おお！おおお！
滑る！すごい滑るよ！
こっちはまだ何もスプレー付けてないじゃないすか
倒れます
こっちだと
ウェウェウェエ
ゴッホゴッホ
すごいすごいすごい！
ひとまずこの机中を全部滑るようにしてみましょう
ウヴぇぇぇ！
完全に滑る机です
え？マジで滑るよ！？
滑るスプレーは本物みたいっすねー
素晴らしい！
じゃあちょっと実際に床で、やってみましょう
靴履くだけでもすーっと滑れるようになるんで
ちょっと実際に作っていきましょう
はい、ちょっと吸い込んじゃダメなのでマスクしながら
とりあえず、滑るスプレーを床に塗っていきます
ではいこう！
まってすごいすごいすごい！
え、ちょっとまって！すごい！
OK!
ちょっとにおいがひど過ぎるんで、乾くのを待ちましょう
はい！というわけでようやく床の準備が整いました
これできっと俺は
小学校のころのすべすべの廊下に戻れる
というわけで今回用意しますのはこちら
見るからに滑りそうな靴を準備しました
俺んちの床でもね、スーッと滑れることをちょっと証明しようと思います
では小学校の廊下の水拭きした後のように
もう最速スピードでだいすけのとこまで行きます
いきます！
３！
２！
１！
ドラッ！
ぬぁ...
ぁ...ぁあ...
だいすけの骨は
俺の心臓を貫通していた
ぶはぁっ
くっ
おほぁっ
だいすけ...
ありがとう...